without world should watch Steven  Jackson business start [ __ ] cook I'm  gonna give him the category run the  [ __ ] run the start and when the cut I'm  gonna start whiskey I'm gonna [ __ ]  tequila and I'm gonna cut back cuz I  don't drink it I'm Tom Brady I'm gonna  start Serena Williams and I'm a brain  tiger off the [ __ ] and the reason why  I'm starting to Reena  because she's the better athlete at all  of them  I would start the car to three Lil Wayne  I'm a I'm a [ __ ] get rich or die  trying' and I'm a cut blueprint not like  all those albums I like I just that's  all one of my favorite albums so it was  a tough I would that telepathy  I will bench super speed and I was  taught super spin now I'm not trying to  read no mind no I'm Stephen Jackson this  is star [ __ ] cut check out the podcast  all the smoke on all platforms demon  podcast and our video on Showtime  YouTube basketball